There's two different sorts of frauds as
I understand it,
to a fraud or corruption of just a lump
them together.
But you've got,
you've got theft corruption in it.
Just to give you,
you know,
could have a,
um,
an example.
And again,
I'm not,
I'm,
I'm not looking to be insulting to,
to the various developing world
governments and to say that they're all
fraudulent and everybody there was
fraudulent.
They're clearly not in some very honest
and a lot of very,
very good people over there.
But some of the challenges become that,
you know,
when the minister of finance transfers
the money to the Ministry of Education,
you know,
there are occasions where some of the
money and it goes the administer of
education convinced that check into
cash,
that cash now's got to get distributed
to the districts.
And then the districts,
I've got to then distribute the cash to
the local parishes,
then the parishes.
I've got to distribute it to the school
masters and to the principals in the
school.
So you can imagine how there could be
situations where some people along that
chain of the cash take their time.
Um,
you know,
along the way and when the,
so by the time the people that the who
are supposed to receive the,
the,
their salary that,
you know,
the hundred percent of the cash that was
a given upfront to the ministry,
there's only 80% left by the time it
gets to the teacher at the bottom end.
Now,
these are the sorts of situations that
have been described to me as being very
typical.
It's not,
it doesn't,
it doesn't always happen in every single
place,
but clearly these are problems.
Um,
and then when the young woman wants to
collect her,
collect her $80 leftover from the
hundred that was originally supposed to
get,
then the,
the person who was supposed to give it
to her very often will abuse the woman
until he actually gives her the money,
cause he's got the power over the money.
Um,
but in addition to that,
there are also many,
many ghost employees in the system
because there are no very good checks
and balances.
So that's one element of the corruption
and the fraud,
which maps system we'll be able to
provide a solution for.
So,
uh,
the governments are very keen to underst
because they'll save a lot of money
because of the,
uh,
the people get paid,
you know,
kind of directly so that people will be
happy.
They'll get paid the amount that they're
supposed to get paid.
So they'll suddenly start finding that
they're saving a lot of money.
Um,
from there,
the time they send out their $1 million
or whatever the number is from the top,
that they'll find that that million
dollars when they actually sent it
directly to the people,
a,
the people will get the money they're
supposed to get for,
there'll be a lot of employees that
didn't really exist.
So that's one level of corruption.
There's another level of corruption,
which is that you have to pay people to
make things happen.
And I haven't thought it through well
enough to see kind of Kemet solution,
uh,
come and help out in that situation.
I don't know if we can solve every
situation,
but in terms of the corruption and the
fraud and the lack of transparency and
the abuse of payments of,
you know,
government type payments to people.
And the pensions,
you know that not everybody gets all the
pension that they're supposed to get
because of the cash distribution.
Those are the sorts of situations that
map solution can provide a,
a a great benefit to develop.
We will government when people aren't
identified,
they just don't exist.
And there's a lot of discussion before
you ask me the next question.
What about the privacy rights?
You know,
kind of of the,
of the people,
if there's,
if,
if the governments are going to have so
much information about the people
because they have their biometrics,
they'll know that I have the health
information and then they'll have some,
they'll have potentially access to some
financial information.
Currently these people don't exist,
so the government has ultimate power
over these people.
The more you enable individuals to
become part of a formal society,
the more freedom they have,
the more economic success they have.
And everybody recognizes that economic
success creates an environment of
stability and peace.
So it's very,
very much in the best interests of the
countries themselves that you know that,
that they can have stability and peace.
It's in the interest of the developing
world to be able to create an
environment where people are happy.
People you know,
kind of ended up that the people exist.
And from a,
from a larger perspective,
today we're dealing in an environment
where there's very limited money
available for an Oda in overseas
development assistance.
So the challenge for the governments is
to find ways to maximize the efficiency
of the money that is being used.
And I believe that by,
for the donor countries,
whether it's partnering through the
World Bank or a USA ID or deferred or
all these agencies,
their ability to identify private sector
companies that will have their own skin
in the game.
And then I've got their own agenda to
ensure some longterm sustainability of
the projects,
that there's the ability for these
companies to leverage the donor money
and convert equity to growth and create
an environment where there'll be,
um,
long term success is the way that
governments need to be looking at.
Um,
they're developing.